this newly released audio of a private
conversation between then candidate
Donald Trump and his fixer is raising
new questions about an alleged cover-up
before the 2016 election mr. Trump and
his longtime lawyer Michael Cohen can be
heard discussing a payment involving
former Playboy model Karen McDougal she
says that she had an affair with mr.
Trump more than a decade ago and the
president has denied that repeatedly
he's denied that Michael Cohen's lawyer
that's Lanny Davis released a secret
recording to CNN last night the move
intensifies a feud between Cohen and
President Trump now CBS News has not
verified the recordings authenticity so
I'm all over that and I spoke to Alan
about it when it comes time for the
financing which will be there is if
there is a dispute rather over what the
tape says and what it actually means
major Garrett is that the White House
was more on this story major good
morning good morning this is one of at
least 12 audio recording seized by the
FBI from Cohen's various properties back
in April there are literally tens of
thousands of other documents now the
president's lawyer Rudy Giuliani said he
did not object to the release of this
tape because he said it proves mr.
Trump's side of the story but the tapes
release is an escalation carried out by
Cohen's legal team and a clear sign of
the estrangement between mr. Trump and
his former friend and fixer I've spoken
to Alan weiselberger about how to set
the whole thing up with
funding yes it's the muffled audio was
secretly recorded by Cohen in 2016
shortly before the election I need to
open up a company for the transfer of
all of that info regarding our friend
David
David is a possible reference to David
pecker mr. Trump's friend and president
of national Enquirer's parent company
American media incorporated so I'm all
over that and I spoke to Alan about it
when it comes time for the financing
which will be the conversation came
after American media Incorporated
reached a $150,000 deal to pay former
Playboy model Karen McDougal for her
story about an alleged affair with mr.
Trump in 2006 the president denies the
affair mr. Trump's lawyer Rudy Giuliani
fired back saying the recording only
proves the president's claims that he
did not know about the transaction and
provided this White House transcript of
the recording which claims that mr.
Trump says don't pay with cash check
everybody heard just now Donald Trump
say the word cash on Monday the White
House deviated from its previous blanket
denials of MacDougall's alleged affair
with mr. Trump the president maintains
that he's done nothing wrong and I would
refer you to Rudy Giuliani SH there's no
question that Michael Cohen has the
goods on the president Michael avenatti
represents adult film star stormy
Daniels to whom Cohen made a payment
shortly before the election to keep
silent about an alleged one-night stand
with the president back in 2006 mr.
Trump has also denied his affair with
Daniels Davis said the recordings reveal
those denials about McDougald are false
this is not a man shocked about Karen
McDougal he knows what they're talking
about American media's of payment
effectively silenced mcdougal throughout
the 2016 campaign now Cohen's lawyer did
not have an explanation for why this
recording was made or nor
why it cuts off abruptly all right major
thank you so much